[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is chapter six of our course about
how to fight efore like Khurana let's
have a look what we are dealing with in
chapter 6 chapter 6 is the problem
deepest in terms of mood count chapter
of them of the whole course and we are
starting already relatively late in the
game so we have the starting moves of
the petrov in now deform in our chapter
5 we have looked at night before already
and this is the sequence that we have
looked at and now in this chapter we're
dealing with everything that happens
after white takes on d7 which is the
main move we've looked at Queen e2 and
some other continuations in chapter 5
but we'll check this and resulting in
lines in this chapter 6 yeah what does
white um yeah White's play is all about
here in this chapter it's all about the
knight on e4 black's knight only for the
petrov Knight is an actively placed
piece and as the structure that black
has is perfectly sound and the
development is also fine I mean we are
ready to play Bishop d6 and Castle
kingside
the play is mostly about white trying to
somehow prove that the night only four
is a liability this is the same story
also in the next two chapters chapter
seven and eight in the over the main
line the white tries to do the same
so what White's play is mostly about is
attacking the knight with moves like a
knight c3 or playing c4 and then I had
c3 to pressurize this piece trying to
make it move again or get some other
concession
our love black we will see that black
actually holds his own quite quite
nicely in this whole chapter however the
lines are at times extremely deep and at
times also extremely sharp so be ready
to look for or really ready to now study
some lines that go far beyond move 20
this is um this chapter is a proof that
studying openings can also yeah means
studying end games we will look at root
endings for example in this opening
course now here in Chapter number six so
let's look at some concrete
continuations here on move seven White's
main move is unsurprisingly to Castle
kingside
and move that you basically cannot play
without long and in the long run and
they have been other tries but they are
at best unspectacular let's say or
downright dangerous rather for white so
let's have a look at some of the
alternatives a very slow ish move this
Knight d2 simply attacking the knight
only for were placing the knight on D to
here black has no problems whatsoever by
simply taking on d2 they just take on d2
and this will equalize completely if you
want a bit of a more complex game you
can also play f5 there is nothing wrong
about this it is slightly weakening but
the e5 square is weakened but something
like we never six and castling long next
is definitely possible however I need to
mention one thing that is simply the
reality in this time there will be a
multitude of lines coming up where you
have a very hard time to avoid draw down
right draw or draw position this is the
nature of a very open tactical opening
where in some cases you have to play
along if you are black if white wants
some
it's sometimes it's very difficult to
avoid
so here five is a playable option to
avoid a draw or avoid a very draw
position but you won't have that option
every single time in the coming lines so
here let's look at 92 which is the
cleanest way to prove that 92 is not
really challenging why it takes and now
it is important to not play
symmetrically with Bishop d6 this is a
little bit imprecise because now if you
Castle and what else is there there is
Queen h5 and we see one issue of this
whole this whole idea that white hands
they're often times if it's quicker
there there's a double attack going on
and T f5 is not particularly great for
black we will see a similar situation
later where White has a double pawn on
the C file and this is fine here there
is no weakness what we have to do is in
this position is to play Queen e7 check
that is a very clean way to equalize now
if white plays Queen e2 we are simply
taking and this is quite clearly
completely equal instead white may also
try to avoid the Queen trade immediately
with Bishop e3 but here the move Queen
before check will equalize because a
pawn sacrifice is just not sound now
here's something that King F 1 or C 3 so
after Queen d2 we will again have
equalized they shouldn't take on B 2
then that's it that is a bit risky
everyone can castle immediately but here
this is quite ready nothing at all has
something like that it's just an equal
position so 792 is extremely harmless
similarly harmless is the other night
move Knight c3 well I have to say it is
not totally harmless just harmless if
why it is not a transpose so we will
take
and play Bishop d6 now if white castles
we will Castle and then we will look at
then this is a position that we will
examine later he will also see the
difference by the way between the
position we looked at like a minute ago
well why did not have a double pawn and
f5 needs to be played here black is fine
because the double pawn is a sort of
compensation for the slight strategic
concession we make with f5 this is a
line that usually happens after white
castles first on move seven and then
Knight c3 this is interesting to check
and we will do so quite shortly action
if however here why does an orc Castle
angling to transpose and place Queen h5
we are again dealing with a fairly
harmless tribe black chicks we should be
three and now the simple move Bishop to
c6 we cover this pawn and we have not
yet Castle so we still have this option
to Castle queenside if white tries to
prepare to prevent that with this we
have Queen d7
and this is completely equal yeah now we
still we can cancel short we can Castle
queenside and here black is quite happy
with the position I think the double
pawn is always something to play for in
the long run so Knight c3 does have very
little independent value it is mostly
transpositional if white castles some on
the on the ninth move okay going back
here there is also the move Queen to e2
this is somewhat similar idea to Queen
e2 one move earlier if we go back a
little bit to chapter five of our course
there we have looked at Queen e2 that
was the classic game cup of lausanne
after taking on d7 and then Queen e2
wide similarly to that to that game to
that line tries to play on the e-file
play with the idea f3 here my suggestion
is to play as we
do against them Queeny to move one move
earlier play aggressively
you can play move the move Queen e7
simply trying to keep the pawn but I
think it is just strong to play Bishop
e7 if white plays I think some kind of
substandard line in the petrov playing
actively is a good recipe here this is
such an option here Queenie 7 I think
it's just too lame now white probably
will grab the pawn if he does not we
will be totally fine after castling and
just retreating the knight yeah because
the Queen is wrong on the e-file in that
case M if you imagine castling Whoopi
aid white but not takes the pawn the
Queen will be misplaced so he were very
likely now grab the pawn so take on e4
and now you can take only for
immediately or you can play Knight c3
after the immediate capture I suggest to
play Bishop to c6 the Queen now has to
move and should probably or will
probably cover the G to pawn for example
Queen g4
if you enjoyed the free video preview
make sure to go to chesterlaw.com slash
fight like a Khurana to get to the full
course the full course with the move
trainer and video sync technology is an
excellent way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
[Music]